sasha's like did you do that math on
your own yes i did six million season
opener and you had a better chance at
nitpicking meryl streep than the rebels
offense 52 big ones on the board kevin
martin breaks this down from every one
of them from allegiance stadium
in his third season as the head coach
for unlv football marcus arroyo picks up
his third ever win you know heading into
this game a lot of questions surrounding
who would start as the quarterback well
doug brownfield got the start and he
showed out and performed on the biggest
stage i saw this opportunity
all my hard work this offseason payoff
you know all the extra workouts we put
in with our guys all the extra film we
put in it's just it was an opportunity
to test our skills you know so i'm just
happy we got to execute that today i
mean that's that's what you want you
want to see if if it translates right i
mean if you can get to a saturday and
the lights come on for the first time i
mean first game they played together you
know him and him and ricky and jeff and
all many of the guys you know preston
and there's just so many there's eight
or nine guys on each side of the ball
that are in the too deep that are on the
field for the first time together so to
see them gel and start getting rhythm
together early that's that's that's
exciting because uh i think that that
says a lot about the the
possibility of what it can become as we
continue to grow now um everything goes
up from here you know everything goes up
as far as who you're playing uh the
stakes and how we expect but um our
standards our standards the process is
is is high and uh i'm excited about
these guys continuing to find the finer
things to work on so now at 1-0 the
rebels hit the road for their next game
as they head to cal to take on the bears
on september 10th reporting at allegion
stadium kevin martin live local now
the ace is